en france le ballon d'oxygène pour les
avions marcel dassault le gouvernement
vient de passer commande un premier
prototype du rafale le rafale est
l'avion de combat qui équipera vous le
savez l'armée de l'air et l'aéronautique
navale à compter de 1996
les contrats signés aujourd'hui sont de
l'ordre de 14 milliards de francs
philippe dumaine il aura fallu presque
deux ans avant de prendre cette décision
les ingénieurs de dassault brayer avait
pourtant réalisé un superbe avion de
démonstration mais les commandes fermes
pour lancer les prototypes ont un peu
tardé
ce n'est qu'après 260 vols d'essai pour
prouver que le rafale et est aussi
l'avion de l'an 2000 que le gouvernement
a passé sa commande destinés à remplacer
les mirages jaguar et autres étendards
le rafale a effectué son premier vol en
juillet 86 il apportera aussi un peu
d'oxygène aux usines dassault et bien je
me fais plaisir parce que tant qu'un
contrat n'est pas signé on n'est pas sûr
de l'avoir et frontignes dans l'émotion
parce que
je pense à mon père qui avait démarré ce
programme et qui tenait beaucoup et qui
représente vraiment un très important
point pour l'avenir de toute industrie
française et notre société en tout ce
sont cinq prototypes qui seront
construits trois pour l'armée de terre
et 2 pour la marine pour l'instant le
contrat ne porte que sur deux
exemplaires et il est d'un montant
estimé à 14 milliards de francs
cette importante décision amènera
certainement quelques pays européens à
vouloir participer à la construction du
rafale et alors les investissements
seront moins l'eau pour chacun des pays
les avions militaires sont de plus en
plus performants mais aussi de plus en
plus cher